bitcoin about 12 years ago got started
on halloween of 2008 the bitcoin white
paper was published on january 3rd 2009
bitcoin was put out into the world at
that time it was a crazy crazy idea in
the corner of the internet no way
could this insane idea ever get any
traction if you fast forward 12 years we
are now at over a trillion dollar market
cap every single financial institution
in the entire world is trying to figure
out what their bitcoin strategy is
there's over a hundred million
individuals that hold bitcoin personally
the average exposure is about four
thousand dollars when you start to look
at corporations like microstrategy tesla
and square they have it on their balance
sheet there's plenty of bitcoin miners
that are publicly traded lots of other
investment firms like galaxy digital et
cetera that also bitcoin another balance
sheet
bitcoin has grown up but the one corner
of the financial system where bitcoin
still has not penetrated it has not been
able to weasel its way in is the banks
and the banks always hide behind
regulation they say we are regulated
entities we cannot participate in this
we're not allowed to those that oversee
us will not let us hold bitcoin hold or
custody bitcoin for our customers or
participate in the various financial
services around bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies but that might change
now the fdic chairman jelena mcwilliams
has just come out yesterday and said
that banks are now
potentially going to be able to custody
and use these assets this is a very very
big deal so first let's talk about the
fdic the fdic when you go to their
website you say what is the fdic it says
the federal deposit insurance
corporation is an independent agency
created by congress to maintain
stability and public confidence in the
nation's financial system it's all about
stability and public confidence to
accomplish this mission the fdic insures
deposits it examines and supervises
financial institutions for safety
soundness and consumer protection and it
makes large and complex financial
institutions resolvable and manages
receiverships so basically the fdic says
hey yo banks you guys do your job if you
don't do your job we're here we got your
back we're going to provide federal
deposit insurance that's the whole point
of the fdic
now you may not know about the fdic that
since its creation in 1933 according to
its website they have been an essential
part of the american financial system in
the 1920s and early 1930s a rise in bank
failures created a national crisis
wiping out many american savings
since the fdic insurance began in 1934
no depositor has lost a single penny of
insured funds due to bank failure so in
the 20s and 30s there was all kinds of
issues banks were failing and people
would quite literally lose their money
if you had a hundred dollars there the
bank failed were out of luck done
fdic stepped in and said we will insure
let's say retail bank accounts up to 250
000 so if you had 250 000 in a bank
account since 1934 to today you've never
lost it because it is insured by the
fdic
very big deal now how many banks are
there the best business show research
team we started to dig into this and try
to understand just how big are the banks
well there are over 4 000 commercial
banks and over 600 saving institutions
so about 5 000 total institutions that
fall under the fdic
they hold approximately 22 trillion
dollars in assets
when we talk about the financial system
the banks or the big boys
22 trillion dollars in assets about 5
000 institutions so if all of a sudden
the fdic is able to come up with
regulation and rules that allows these 5
000 institutions to get in the game it
would be a very very big deal you would
see a massive increase in demand and for
something like bitcoin that has a fixed
supply if there is a massive increase in
demand and a fixed supply asset the us
dollar price has to appreciate to
accommodate everyone it's just simple
supply and demand economics 101. so we
go ahead and we look at what jolena
mcwilliams stated the first quote is if
we don't bring this activity inside the
banks it is going to develop outside of
the banks the federal regulators won't
be able to regulate it and so she's
clearly stating that it is obvious that
the retail users the investors the
depositors they want this product this
technology has found product market fit
and that activity is only going to
continue and it will continue inside or
outside of the regulator's purview
if they do not act and so therefore if
the fdic and regulators decide to come
up with a rule set so that banks can get
in the game
then that activity or some portion of it
will start to actually permeate into the
banks and there will be lots of progress
and activities that the banks can
participate in so this is very
forward-thinking in my opinion because
you have the chairman of the fdic saying
this is real people want it and it is
not going to reverse the trend will not
go backwards it is only going to go
forward from here
we can choose to participate or to sit
this one out but if we have 5 000
institutions and 22 trillion dollars of
assets and there is a brand new
financial system being built a brand new
financial asset that we have no ability
to interface with we should probably
change that if we then go and we look at
the second quote she said the issue
there and she's specifically talking
about banks being able to have bitcoin
holdings for client trading collateral
for loans or held as assets on their
balance sheet so the issue there is
valuation of these assets and the
fluctuation in their value can be almost
on a daily basis you have to decide what
kind of capital and liquidity treatment
to allocate to such balance sheet
holdings so the whole idea here would
not just be for the bank to invest in
bitcoin what they're specifically
talking about is for the banks to go
ahead and gather bitcoin to
convert cash into bitcoin put it on
their balance sheet and then to use the
bitcoin on their balance sheet for
trading for their clients to allow
clients to buy and sell bitcoin to allow
it to serve as collateral for loans
again bitcoin is the most pristine
collateral in the world
and it will also allow the banks to
simply hold it on their balance sheet so
it's not just about the financial gain
of the banks but it's also about
allowing bitcoin to serve as an asset in
financial services this is ultimately
how bitcoin goes from a simply an
investable global store value to
actually being incorporated into the
global financial system in a way that
most people have thought would not
happen
now if we go ahead and we think about
how they are doing this we obviously
have the chairwoman of the fdic spending
a ton of time publicly stating this and
saying we are working on back in may
there was something called a sprint team
that sprint team was announced in may
and it has the goal of ensuring that
crypto policy coordination among three
bank regulators the fdic is one of them
the federal reserve is the second and
the office of the comptroller of the
currency the occ is the third so what
you now have is not just the fdic
chairperson saying hey we want to get
banks in the game we're trying to figure
out how to do that but we also can go
back to may and see that they put
together a team to get the fdic the
federal reserve and the occ all on board
to get fixed in the game
i don't know what the rules will end up
being i don't know what the timeline is
for them to get there but it is obvious
to me now that the banks will get into
bitcoin and as we know again whether
you're an individual you're a
corporation you're a financial
institution or you're a nation state
bitcoin is good for business and the
banks have been sitting on the sidelines
and they do not want to sit there
anymore and so when we see the banks get
into the bitcoin game my guess is that
they're gonna realize bitcoin is the
best thing for their business